I never had the grand intention that I
wanted to be an accordion store owner
when I grew up I had seen accordions
before but until I actually picked one
out and played the notes and move the
bellows I just was one of those moments
where where has it's been all my life I
am the owner of one of the largest
accordion shops in the world I started
with the accordion when I was about to
head off to college I was trying to
figure out how I was going to play a
piano there and remembered that my dad
played accordion it's really great to
get to know my dad through something
that he really liked and something that
was important to him which was music he
unfortunately died when I was 5 years
old so I really didn't know him very
well you know the ability to to connect
I think is something that I always wish
I had with my dad but you know I look
forward to to having with renewing my
son started on any toy accordion at age
2 I think if he's anything like me or my
dad then he'll like music and it's
perfectly fine with me if he plays
another instrument just want to
ultimately be able to connect with him
and it's a great experience to to
express yourself through a musical
instrument
I think this one's really great sound
for like a tango music possibly could
also pass us as count Dracula's private
accordion I sometimes use that in
combination with my Dracula Fang costume
probably should cut that part in the US
there's very few people they know a lot
about accordions and they can repair
them many of the people that had that
knowledge were retiring and really not
interested in expanding out to the
Internet we started in my apartment
you know just listing things on eBay and
we realized that doesn't create business
model it's amazing to just type in a few
keywords and we see new and used
accordions from all over the world reed
is growing up in an environment where he
sees accordions all the time so
naturally he thinks that a lot of people
play the accordion and he gets to see me
perform he gets to see my band polka
Delphia perform I'm looking forward to
connecting with my son often wished my
dad the most important thing for me is
to instill that sense of finding what he
really likes and something that he'll
wake up each day and